buenas tardes mi queridos amigos desde
méjico
aquí les saluda al y warner osuna soy
ingeniero espacial aquí trabajo en la
nasa james en los eeuu en san francisco
yo me dedico a desarrollar tecnología
que nos lleve a misiones a la luna ya
marte
a cuánto tiempo tengo aquí en los eeuu
tengo desde que tenía 14 años entonces
son como más de 30 años ya estoy aquí en
los eeuu
cómo fue que llegué yo aquí a los a la
nasa bueno pues me
mi caminito fue diferente que lo que uno
a la tradicional se puede decir no
porque yo no fui yo no me agradó la
diversidad llegué luego luego quiera a
la danza si no hay un camino diferente y
yo les voy a decir desde a cuando me
vine de méxico fue por las cuestas que
lo bueno fue por el terremoto que hubo
en méxico al menos 1985 mi familia mi
madre no era madre soltera no podía
a sobresalir con cuatro hijos ayudan la
mayor en aquel tiempo entonces se le
hizo muy difícil para ella poder
sobresalir en una ciudad que estaba
completamente en ruinas
y entonces sería decidió que lo mejor
para nosotros era ver en nuestros
estados unidos
entonces me acuerdo que regresando de la
escuela aún un día y el último día de
escuela regresé a la escuela y mi mamá
dijo nos vamos mañana y así es que
agarrar lo que tu ropa y ya mañana nos
vamos y pusimos dos maletas y esas dos
maletas con todas nuestras cosas que
podíamos llevarnos y nos vinimos para
los estados unidos entonces cuando
cuando llegamos aquí el socio es
obviamente fue muy difícil porque tenía
que aprender el inglés el idioma también
yo tenía familia toda mi familia hemos
dejado en méxico mi abuelo mi abuelo
paterno a querer compadre normal afuera
era la única persona que yo pensé que
por ello si vamos a regresar verdad
porque pues es la persona que
básicamente nos cree a nosotros con mamá
y desafortunadamente al mes de haber
llegado estos sonidos él fallece
entonces cuando eso pasa absolutamente
yo dije nunca no vamos a regresar a
méxico porque
yo sé que mi abuelo era como él el que
de alguna forma nos iba a hacer llegar
otra vuelta a méxico no porque era él
pues era la persona más allegado a
nosotros que queríamos más entonces
cuando él muere obviamente para nosotros
fue como decir miedo para que podemos
para qué vamos a regresar a méxico no
entonces este ahí fue donde yo realicé a
los 14 años que ya nunca además iba a
regresar a méxico que aquí me iba a
quedar nostros unidos entonces cuando
eso pasa pues obviamente y no fue
demasiado difícil
yo personalmente pienso que tenía que mi
madre o sea con toda la cara de los
otros cuatro a fue demasiado para ella y
también para nosotros y cuando yo estaba
yendo a la high school el que se para
aquí a los 18 años yo cumplí 28 años y
mamá me dijo sabes que tienes que ir a
trabajar porque si no no puedo hacerlo
yo sola entonces obviamente el siguiente
día me mandó a trabajar y empecé a
trabajar
y lo hice como por cinco años pero
cuando me gradué de la de la
preparatoria
yo esperaba ir a la universidad porque
eso siempre había sido mi plan y yo y
mis estudios pues afortunadamente no
estamos aquí había pasado una ley
antiinmigrante de 1985 aquí en
california que realmente no era muy
muy racista no entonces esa ley decía
que si tú como persona te veías
diferente hablar idiomas diferentes de
bestias diferente que un policía a una
enfermera la maestra podría poder
detenerte llamar a la policía para que
te deportar a no porque no tú no
pertenecía a esta sociedad entonces
cuando eso pasó pues la verdad yo pensé
que no iba a poder ir a la universidad
porque el gas en ese momento de la
situación y no te pedían muchos papeles
y documentación y obviamente pues con
muchos a pensar habíamos llegado y
teníamos y en el proceso estábamos en
camino
el proceso para establecernos aquí
nuestros unidos pues muchas de esas
cosas no se nos sean complicadas
y entonces mi mamá conocí a una persona
que estaba en el comedor y coles que es
un colegio comunitario aquí cuando puede
ser dos años de la universidad y luego
transferir solamente a la universidad
para hacer los últimos dos años esa
persona le llama mano que había un
programa y que no había problemas si
podíamos y nosotros yo podía empezar el
colegio y luego más en un futuro
transferirme la verdad entonces vino con
esa opción dije bueno
voy a ir al colegio aquí estamos dentro
sofía el colegio san josé pero como
usted se puede imaginar una persona
joven unos 19 20 años
teniendo el cargo de tener que trabajar
140 horas para poder sustentar la
familia y luego no haberte venido de
méxico y no tener familiares que no
haber subido había muchos había muchas
cosas que como persona te
muy bien uruguay entonces cuando yo
llegué cuando estaba yendo al colegio
pues obviamente esa carga emocional
lleva un mes
completamente me da y me sacó de mi
camino entonces yo pensé que lo mejor
era poder
tener un tiempo a salir de la escuela y
demás dedicarme a trabajar porque no
podía emocionalmente era demasiado para
mí entonces salí de la escuela y empecé
a trabajar y entonces cuando estaba
trabajando
pues conocí a alguien y empecé a tener
mis hijos tengo cuatro hijos ahorita
y cuando mi hija la menor tenía un año a
mis dos niños de medio los
diagnosticaron con problemas con las
habilidades mentales entonces a
consecuencia de eso yo me tuve que
educar tuve me tuve que ir a la librería
hay aquí de san jose a leer libros sobre
sus diagnósticos ahora con sus doctores
con las enfermeras y ver cómo yo como
madre podría ayudar a mis hijos entonces
cuando mis hijos estaban en
y dos chiquitos pues obviamente me volví
como su árbol que excelencia y en ese en
esa en sus manos con donde yo me estaba
educando personalmente
había uno de los estudios que decían que
siendo como padre entiendo
una educación tus hijos no iban a poder
sobresalir
aquí van a tener a la ciudad había tres
estadísticas y niños así como mis hijos
que probablemente iban a terminar
muriéndose jóvenes o ser drogadictos o
estar encarcelados entonces yo para mí
fue como un
a despertar decir que voy a ser yo de mi
vida y como poder ayudar a mis hijos
entonces decidí en ese momento que yo
iba a regresar a la escuela que yo iba a
carrera con un diploma de grey y que yo
iba a ir a trabajar para poder tener ese
estabilidad que mis hijos necesitaban
entonces
en cuanto mi hija tenía el mi hija la
menor estaba entrando a quien yo decidí
empezar a trabajar y trabaje por un año
y junte dinero para poder regresar a la
escuela y luego me hice yo misma me hice
un plan de seis meses y un plan de cinco
años y yo lo revisaba cada mes de seis
meses lo revisaba cada seis meses para
ver que iba en el camino para hacer mi
meta de cinco años y pues me regresé al
colegio y lo empecé desde cero otra
vuelta
obviamente en ese momento estaba
trabajando dos trabajos de los hijos y
estaba en la escuela fontana
en fin entonces cuando me estaba
grabando del vino del colegio que eran
los dos años más bien dice dos años y
medio y me dijeron bueno aquí
universidad de las transferir y
obviamente yo porque no tenía o sea con
cuatro hijos donde me voy a ir nats y
les dije que sí que está bien cerquita
entonces cuando me transfer assange
statement me dan la opción y no que
carrera es la que usted yo no quería yo
hacer entonces en ese momento yo va a
todas las carreras que hay y una de
ellas era la ingeniería aeroespacial y
entonces yo dije bueno pues de ahí soy
porque yo cuando estaba en méxico cuando
estaba creciendo mi mamá que no tiene
educación que su educación no fue más
que de seis sexto grado
allí le encantaban leer los libros y yo
me acuerdo que le tocaban la puerta a
todos los todas las semanas había un
señor que le daba la
ya no le vendía un libro y mamá lo
compraba entonces yo llegaba de la
escuela y me sentaba en la sala leer el
libro a ver las fotografías que tenía el
libro de lo que fuera no entonces me
acuerdo yo que tenías como siete años y
estaba viendo el nuevo libro que traían
que habían comprado y había visto el
space aro y es el vehículo que va a
llevar los astronautas y no al espacio
la tarea hacer a poner la estación
espacial y hacer un montón de
expediciones y un extraterrestre no
entonces me cautivó completamente a mí
es ese
esa innovación entonces yo quería saber
quién eran los que lo habían construído
y entonces en ese momento yo dije bueno
pues yo quiero saberlo entonces vi y era
eran los ingenieros aeroespaciales y en
ese momento yo decidí bueno quiero yo
quiero hacerlo yo quiero estudiar una
ingeniería aeroespacial yo quiero ser
ingeniero espacial a los 7 años yo ya
sabía que eso era lo que quería entonces
cuando yo estaba quien en san josé yendo
escogiendo la carrera y vi que tenía un
ingeniero especial obviamente mis
recuerdos de niña
mi ilusión obviamente totalmente de
género se quiso entonces dije aquí yo
quiero ser ingeniero espacial y pues
escogí la carrera no fue fácil porque
también en esos momentos yo cuando
empecé la ingeniería espacial lanzamos
este ir yo me quedo como madre soltera
con mis cuatro hijos y pues fue difícil
no entonces en vez de tardar me dos años
me tardé tres años porque tuve que tener
lleno no pude ser a food and student
tuve que tuve unos momentos en que yo
tuve que hacer a part time y entonces
cuando yo estoy en la universidad y me
estoy graduando mi profesor de la
universidad me dice ali qué es lo que
piensa hacer contigo y tras grabar y
bueno lo único que viese él era el
diploma porque me garantiza no tener un
trabajo estable y poder y no proveer a
mis hijos entonces me dice bueno hay dos
cosas que yo quiero que tú pienses no y
una es que tienes que invertir en ti
mismo
puedes venir otra vuelta a la escuela
agarrar tu maestría y no son dos años
más
y no invierte sentido y la otra es que
hay una una intro en chip en la ceim y
yo obviamente la primera que era la
venir a esa universidad se me hizo súper
fácil porque dije bueno si lo estoy
haciendo por varios años puede hacer lo
mismo por dos años más o sea no el
problema pero la intrinsic pena se me
hizo un poco difícil pero fuera de mi
alcance porque dije bueno si yo voy a
ayuda como latina como persona adulta
con cuatro hijos viendo a ir aa nasa
aplica pues obviamente no no soy muy
especial no creo que me lo den y
profesor me dijo al ciudadano no lo ves
de esa forma y no tienes que verlo de
que vas a ir aprender algo te van a ser
ese nervio vas a poder aprender algo de
lo que ellos te están este de lo que
están preguntando y si tú no te la dan
puedes ir a otro trabajo y de lo que
aprendices en ese nervio lo vas a poder
aplicar lo que en la otra que va a ser y
tal vez y no sacar es un trabajo
y entonces yo en ese aspecto pues dije
bueno si es una oportunidad para
aprender y entonces a piqué pasó un mes
y no me había hablado entonces yo dije
bueno ya se olvidaron de milán o sea
pero resulta que me mandaron un correo
una semana después y me dijeron sabes
que allí te tienes que aparecer el día
tres horas aquí aquí en la nasa y pues
simplemente me ya me habían dado la
oportunidad de tener ese intensivo y la
intención no ha sido hacer por tres
meses y yo dije bueno pues nada por tres
meses no hay problema producto lo que yo
puedo aprender para poder después en
tres meses ir a buscar un trabajo
y después de los tres meses mi jefe me
sabes que estamos a extender la intro
por un año y me les tendieron por todo
un año y al año me dijeron sabes que él
y concept e contratista general y fui
contratista general entonces ya al año
yo ya estaba casi terminando en mi
carrera de ingeniería aeroespacial como
con mi maestría no
y entonces me dicen sabes que van a
abrir una posición de quien nace del
psib observan para también la ingeniería
porque no aplicas corte lo pueden dar
entonces yo a pique no pensando que me
la iban a dar pero no me califique y
pues desde entonces he sido estoy aquí
como ingeniero espacial y servidora
pública del gobierno y me dedico a hacer
pequeños satélites se fijan atrás de mí
tengo diferentes fotografías
este es el de project cristianización
espacial que sacan a los satélites aquí
está uno de mis últimos satélites que se
pueden dar cuenta ustedes aquí este y
hago tecnología de nuestra tecnología
que podamos que podamos utilizar para ir
a la luna oa marte no
y ahora qué es lo que quiero son ideas
del futuro cuando yo pienso que hay un
montón de oportunidades en el futuro
especialmente para méxico porque tienes
a mixco tiene
demasiada gente que es joven que puede
aprender y tienen la oportunidad de
poder ir a expander esa esa mente y no a
hacer ingenierías y ciencias es lo más
importante porque realmente somos los
que vamos a resolver los problemas de el
siguiente este mundo que está ahorita en
teniendo varios problemas climatológicos
puede decir no entonces es importante
que la educación de ingenierías y
ciencias hace algo que uno sea de
nuestra sociedad en en fases porque son
vamos a tener que resolver problemas muy
difíciles que no nos encontrarán no nos
hemos tenido hasta ahorita no
obviamente para mí el futuro de él
el ingeniero espacial y pienso que en
unos cuantos años tal vez podamos
regresar otra vuelta a la luna y poder
hacer grandes expediciones y aprender un
poco más de nuestro sistema solar
también y no muchas veces la gente no
piensa sobre lo que nos ha hecho y cómo
nos ha influenciado pero yo pienso que
es algo que deberíamos tomar en
consideración porque si nosotros fuimos
a la luna en los años 60 pero de toda
esta tecnología que se desarrolló ahora
tenemos las computadoras tenemos nuestro
teléfono tenemos baterías
todo eso fue resultado del research y
son anza y la inversión que el gobierno
americano puso para poder llevar al ser
humano a la luna entonces obviamente
nosotros ya fuimos pero toda esa nueva
tecnología que podamos desarrollar va a
ser realmente increíble
y va a reservar para beneficio para
nosotros también
entonces él ha tenido la idea el futuro
para mí es que es algo que
constantemente yo yo yo pienso que es lo
que puede pasar pero realmente no me la
puedo imaginar porque no es puede ser
tan innovadora hay demasiadas cosas que
todavía hay que descubrir hay que
resolver y yo pienso que es súper
interesante
les puedo contar no puedo pasar aquí
todo y de las cosas que yo pienso de
propulsión sobre y no cámaras para ir de
poder ver el agua o minerales en la
tierra y cómo pueden esas cosas de este
ayudarnos en nuestro nuestro día a día
en esta humanidad la agricultura los
materiales que podemos hacer en la
estación espacial y no comida que se
puede ser la cena especial y traer o sea
etcétera etcétera y un montón de cosas
que les puedo decir que es que es súper
innovador y yo sé que me tarde que todo
un día diciéndoles lo que es ponen fin a
me dio un gusto poder compartir con
ustedes cuando ustedes un momento y
espero en algún día poder estar allá en
monterrey y saludarlos que tengan un día
bye